[Applause]  [Applause]  squish boy  boss wants to see you in trouble someone  is  this man betrayed our trust  you've saved my life we are going home  i don't have a home not yours  mine i can't change your past  but i can offer you a purpose  for 600 years our ninja have brought  peace  to the world i believe in you  [Music]  all right what do i have to do  now the three challenges of the warrior  the three challenges in the what now  if you survive you'll gain access to our  knowledge  and our power  cobra is coming that's cobra a shadow  organization devoted to global  revolution  i've been following you for some time do  i know you  i know you snake eyes  join us  [Music]  you